I'd like to discuss the first sign of a
magnesium deficiency did you realize
that 68 of people in the United States
don't get the required amounts of
magnesium from their diet now not to
mention all the other foods and things
and drugs and things that people are
exposed to that deplete magnesium
magnesium is a cofactor involved in
350 different enzymes what's a cofactor
cofactor is something that is required
by an enzyme for that enzyme to work and
I'm not just talking about digestive
enzymes I'm talking about enzymes that
make up all your biochemistry that do
all the bodily functions the other thing
about a magnesium deficiency is many
times a potassium deficiency has very
similar symptoms so it's it is difficult
to determine if you have a magnesium
deficiency or a potassium deficiency but
the good news is they both come from
vegetables and salads so as long as you
already knows you're going to be totally
fine but before I get into the number
one most common symptom let me go
through some other symptoms
cramping twitching which could also come
from other things as well like your pH
being two alkaline arrhythmias okay of
the heart the heart starts skipping
because of a lack of magnesium mainly
because magnesium works with calcium
magnesium helps remove too much calcium
from the cell helping this over
contracted vasoconstricted artery
lowering your blood pressure now as far
as your bone health people think calcium
to prevent osteoporosis but magnesium is
just as important and osteomalacia which
is a vitamin D deficiency which is
softening of the bones in adults like a
child's version would be rickets because
magnesium is essential for vitamin D
activation you can't activate vitamin D
without magnesium insulin resistance and
I've talked about this in many other
videos has a related magnesium
deficiency usually and this is why when
you increase magnesium you start to make
insulin more sensitive and it starts to
work and of course insomnia if you don't
have enough you'll have a tendency to
not be able to sleep and also low
magnesium can raise cortisol and of
course your mood is dependent on
magnesium too if you're a deficient in
magnesium you may find that you're a bit
on the depressed side so what is the
number one symptom of a magnesium
deficiency it is fatigue now so many
people have fatigued and maybe you right
now are sitting right there and you're
tired right A lot of people are tired it
could be as simple as not getting enough
magnesium and I do want to mention what
foods to eat for magnesium because
that's ultimately the best way to get
your magnesium but let me just dive into
why people get tired because they don't
have enough magnesium
remember I mentioned that magnesium is
necessary for 350 different enzymes well
a lot of those enzymes are in the
mitochondria and specifically the
creation of ATP ATP is the energy
currency that the body uses to power all
the different functions and magnesium
Powers something else that I talked
about in other videos the sodium
potassium pumps these are the little
pumps in every single cell that power
your muscles to work and your nervous
system to work that little pump creates
the voltage because your cells are like
batteries well guess what magnesium
provides the energy to allow for that
pump to pump so this is why you might
have cramps there's just not enough
power to allow that sodium potassium
pump to work in the muscles and things
start shutting down and you cramp this
is why the electricity cannot be
traveled through
the pacemaker of your heart correctly
and if that can't work you start getting
arrhythmias or palpitations or your
heart starts to skip because you don't
have the energy because there's no
magnesium to power that sodium potassium
pump in the nervous system magnesium is
also needed to make proteins protein
synthesis also needed to make DNA and
RNA the building blocks of everything
now most people are deficient because
it's just not eating enough of the right
food to prevent this problem and the
food that will give you the most
magnesium is leafy greens vegetables big
salads the cool thing it will also give
you the potassium so when you eat Foods
whether at a restaurant or at home and
you have this little side salad that's
just like one cup it's just not going to
be enough you need to beef up your
salads no pun intended to the point
where if you're doing like two meals a
day I would say you know have like five
cups or just get it out of the way and
eat like seven cups of salad just one
time a day now ideally if you go a
little bit more it's a little bit better
but I think you should work on a nice
gradual increase in your salad but the
point is that most people don't consume
enough salad even Associates friends
family members around myself I see what
they're eating and they just don't have
enough salad so when I go to a social
activity and they bring out the meals
right they have a big salad bowl and
you'll put your salad on the plate with
all the other food
now you need an extra bowl in addition
to your play to put that huge salad and
of course I'm usually the only one that
does that in my circles but the point is
that I don't have any arrhythmias I
don't get any cramps I had tons of
energy because I have enough magnesium
if you don't do that or can't do that
we'll definitely start using a
supplement I would recommend magnesium
glycinate that's a good one
but there's three types of magnesium I
would not recommend okay the magnesium
oxide the magnesium hydroxide and the
magnesium carbonate those might be okay
maybe as a laxative but other than that
I wouldn't take them because they're not
very absorbable the other ways that
people are deficient are they eat too
many refined Foods especially
fructose which is in table sugar it's in
honey it's in high fructose corn syrup
it's in a lot of other things as well
but fructose can deplete magnesium
alcohol and what is alcohol made from
sugar the more inflammation you have the
less magnesium you're going to have in
your body if you want to know a good
biomarker on a blood test for a
magnesium deficiency look at something
called C-reactive protein that's an
inflammatory biomarker and it usually
means that you need more magnesium also
certain medications like especially
diuretics can create a magnesium
deficiency as well as antibiotics when
you have this alteration in your
microbiome probably from a combination
of several things what happens is
there's a certain thing that will start
binding up and locking up a lot of the
magnesium and a lot of people start
developing musculoskeletal issues like
fibromyalgia painful trigger points a
lot of muscular problems because you
need magnesium for that normal
relaxation days of the contraction and
relaxation cycle now if you wanted a
better visualization of how much salad
you need to eat to get your magnesium
watch this video right here